hello one welcome to this video playing
shallow more probably pronouncing this
wrong cardiac water and German ok h6
it's a rare line and I have a rare
handsome with Knight f3 which i think is
pretty good so let's see how shallow
mama is handling his situation in the
center I like White's chances yeah quite
a bit we'll see how he fares probably
said black loses lots of time with this
age 6 business moving the Queen around
and so mmm night to be five is already
on the agenda and let's see what he does
about that castles ok so i can take on
c7 now yeah let's do it just take with
the bishop it should be a relatively
simple approach and still pretty good
yeah interesting question can i go a 4
here or not I don't really need to so
let's just drop back and play play it
with normal moves okay if I go back to
e3 now k night reform doesn't seem like
a vacation
all right what I really want to do is
open up that diagonal if I get the g one
sorry g 2 i'm bishop into the game i'm
pretty much getting a good attack ok is
going for this trade okay Queenie fourth
what I wanted to do anyway so let's see
I want to take with a king I don't want
Queen age three to happen before is
hanging now and if you take sit93 gets
my night back into the game
okay that's a useful move so let's go
whoopsie one
yeah I can take you for now with the
knight Knight takes e4 Queen takes
before is working I think
you
grabbing a second poem and the noid
hangs on your phone so he has to has to
drop it back so Knight to g5 very likely
is coming up I wonder if I can take yet
another pawn no not so much for the porn
but Queen to be three trying to track
Quincy will go 95 for sure let's go on I
have three I have to have to get this
out of this e 1 square I should forget
that my queen is somewhat attacked so
and 95 I know it's I should have thought
about a little bit
okay so he can now give me a triple
bonds but it's still a good position the
Queen's get traded
it's not ideal I'll just leave it the
reason why this is so good is that there
is this this pinning situation check
okay um how to do this
still not so easy because the double
pony is not worth much I'm a king is
slightly I'm slightly in trouble check
in trouble is wrong but it's not not so
nice so I've got this covered you might
try to come around but i canít mp5 now
which it covers
III is a good square for the king
now this looks good now
takes tanks from age three take stinks I
get this one up
I'll get the Jeep on that's what I was
Kelly I'm oiling check check now I've
got to two connected passes I should do
the trick
check check check check check check
check check mate okay so let's go back
yeah this line with age 60 is played
sometimes it looks a bit strange but it
has been played by strong players
including Magnus Carlsen however I think
that white has a very good replying idea
three that somehow is not played I don't
know why I think white is just better
him a little bit at least efore is one
possibility or on 96 place no I just
know he plays a moose okay and yeah
buddy 5 doesn't work right I can take it
but anyway so 96 castles um yeah you for
and the thing is that after before he
has to he struggles with this you for
porn um what he can do is of course
something like d5 but this is
transposing into basically a reverse
dragon wear black has played the
somewhat uses move age six so if four is
kind of fun yeah its principles let's
say but white is better here
this position no doubt this yeah maybe I
should have taken only four ya first but
this is this a strong as well and
probably this is better immediately
taking him this kind of thing because
now black cannot even cancel long this
is good for white but still yeah the
engine prefers to take with the night
maybe this is really bad yeah small is
winning for white guy here this is a
song a little bit less clear because it
is still very messy they form chicks
Teague's and the engine is just giving
misgiving plus one so no this is this is
good at the computer unsurprisingly
wants to grab g5 as well and I couldn't
really couldn't really do it yeah but
it's probably strong I mean all this is
not really working I can I can take it
it's easier said then done for you man
playin ok this is keeping a big edge and
I'm getting the Queen's off check it
just at g5 hanks and there is no good
move here 94 was a good alternative but
this is also strong check check yeah I
think I'm reasonably happy with the
technical part here killed all his cowl
to play and then here transpose into a
winning winning ending yeah this line
with lighter 3 is pretty good i don't
know why it's never played of course h6
is a sideline in the first place but
still ok well thanks for watching